malgré la neige et le manque de
visibilité
les enquêteurs ont pu mettre au jour la
quasi totalité du squelette de maylis
ainsi que des vêtements et une chaussure
à l'endroit même où le crâne et un os de
la petite fille avait été découvert hier
ce soir les opérations de recherches
sont donc terminés mais l' enquête n'est
pas fini pour autant
il s'agit désormais de comprendre
comment est morte maylis dans quelles
circonstances un laboratoire mobile et
une vingtaine d'experts de lire ses
gènes
l'institut de recherche criminelle de la
gendarmerie sont sur place toutes les
facettes du crime seront travaillés nous
avons un médecin légiste sur place nous
avons un anthropologue qui est
particulièrement bien formés à l'examen
des traces et des blessures qu'on
pourrait retrouver sur les os ou sur
l'ensemble des corps ou des vêtements et
ensuite nous avons aussi des
spécialistes en faune flore forensic qui
vont étudier l'environnement et milieu
pour vérifier qu'il a déposé le corps il
ya cinq ou six mois pourquoi et comment
l'ancien maître chien et il passait aux
aveux
aujourd'hui on en sait un peu plus une
tâche de sang appartenant à maylis
découverte sous le tapis dans le coffre
de la voiture du meurtrier présumé a
sans doute été décisive
le landais a peut-être céder devant ce
nouvel élément à charge dans cette
affaire en fait à plusieurs reprises en
aide
on a amené le suspect à devoir infirmer
la première version qui nous avait livré
et progressivement à le pousser
je dirais dans un dans un coin en fait
où il n'a plus d'autre solution que
d'avouer nordahl le landais dit avoir
tué maïlys de façon accidentelle
il a aussi indiqué à son avocat qu'il
expliquerait son geste plus tard de
nouvelles auditions sont donc prévues
dans les jours à venir